a lot of people like to rely on
i'm so depressed i just i just can't
kick this depression i don't know what
to do
what do i do rich how do i kick the
depression well
first of all get off the stupid meds
okay there's been lots of studies
there's a couple of ted talks on it even
now i think out there if you look them
up but
ssris antidepressants get off the damn
meds
they make you fat they make you numb
they make you have no sexual desire
whatsoever
they don't do anything good for you all
they do is they just basically
zombify you they put you in a complacent
state
where you don't really care and if
that's your objective where you just
don't really want to care and you want
to be medicated by a pharmaceutical
company
sitting around like a blob
you're never going to kick you know
being at the bottom of the barrel you're
never going to kick being zeroed out
that's the starting point the point
after that
is one of the best things that you can
do
to beat feeling bummed out and depressed
go to the gym like
have you ever seen what was that
documentary uh pumping iron with arnold
schwarzenegger
i remember when i saw this when i was
younger he's talking about like i'm
coming in the bedroom and when i go to
the gym and i get the pump i'm coming in
the gym as well and it's like i'm coming
everywhere and it's like
it's like dude's coming everywhere when
he's talking about it but truthfully
when you go to the gym and you get that
pump and you get the endorphins running
through your body and you
feel good you can't feel the press it's
impossible to feel depressed nobody
walks out of a good workout feeling
depressed they feel good
they feel uplifted they feel strong move
get outside breathe fresh air start with
a walk
you know go for a hike get a mountain
bike and ride a trail
get out under the sun the vitamin d is
good for you don't put on sunscreen
sunscreen again one of the things we
covered with dr anthony j when we talked
about his
s regeneration book is all sunscreens
that
aren't zinc based are bad for you
they're estrogenic
okay uh it's and and
having your endocrine uh serum levels
off topic
it's gonna make you depressed dude
if you're walking around with man boobs
you're gonna feel depressed because
you're estrogenic in your body
there's like there's just no two ways
about it yeah like
as a guy you have to learn these lessons
and take ownership for your life because
nobody's gonna do it for you nobody's
gonna hold your hand and say
all right kyle come on over here follow
me let's go talk about you know
why you have man boobs and you're fat
and depressed and no girls want to talk
to you and you can't beat anybody up and
you can barely walk upstairs
without losing your breath right
it's something that you guys have to
take ownership for and start working on
for yourself
and guess what work is dressed in
overalls and it looks hard
because it's work you have to do the
work
right so the whole you know kicking
depression and mental issues i don't
believe in any of that crap to be honest
with you i don't believe in
antidepressants i don't think that the
right solution
i don't think that they're good for you
in fact all the data says that are not
good for you
and there's no reason for you to be
bummed out if
nobody that's having successive wins in
life is bummed out
nobody there's nobody's again there's
nobody there's no guy sitting in a
parking lot with a hot chick in his car
crying in his lamborghini
from all the success that he's had in
his life if you want to kick depression
and success
start having some small successive wins
if you have debt if you have fifty
thousand dollars worth of credit card
debt over
five or six different products just pay
off the smallest one and feel good about
that start with something small
have small success when start somewhere
i'm not saying
you know like how do you eat an elephant
it's one bite at a time sort of thing
right you just start
the worst thing that you can do is be
inactive and not do anything whatsoever
in the absence of clarity do something
i promise you some clarity will come
from moving from doing something
you